bibi netanahou avec le Qatar faisait
financer Hamas alors on sait pas le
montant il y en avait beaucoup donc
chaque mois l'avion du Qatar arrivé à
l'aéroport bengouron les gens ne savent
pas tellement ça avec 10 à 30 millions
était ensuite amené qu'voyaer par le
mossadjip de grand luxe jusqu'à la
frontière des r celle qui a été passée
si facilement dans l'autre sens et là
les services égyptiens l' amené
au-dessous sans doute de l'hôpital
alchifa où c'était réparti évidemment le
Hamas prenait des frais de dossier qui
était sans doute non négligeable et et
donc tout ça pourquoi parce que
netanahou avec la bénédiction américaine
et Cera finançait le ramas parce que ça
permettait d'éviter la cocotte minute et
comme autrefois on disait en France
j'aime tellement l'Allemagne que j'en
veux deux les Israéliens
l'establishement d'Israélien aimait
tellement la Palestine qu'elle en
voulait deux et que la ramass ça
permettait d'avoir une alternative à une
OLP qui avait construit une
respectabilité internationale après
avoir juré qu'elle abandonnait pour
toujours le terrorisme et de dire vous
voyez ce sont ces typesl sont monstrueux
comment voulez-vous qu'on fasse les
choses avec eux donc aujourd'hui le même
qui fait bombarder la bande de Gaza et
celui qui la faisait financer à travers
à travers le Qatar
[Musique]
autrefois